hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the eighth of august today and you're
watching out top five show where we
bring you five awesome stories and none
of the bad ones first up Mass Effect
director and bioware staple Casey Hudson
has elected to leave the studio Hudson
said the decision was the most difficult
of his career but he felt the change was
necessary he discussed Bioware's new IP
in hugely favorable terms saying he
thinks that it will redefine interactive
entertainment as for the new Mass Effect
game Hudson said development is well
underway he said the new installment
will be the best Mass Effect experience
to date and that another of iowa's
projects Dragon Age Inquisition is truly
ambitious with some of the most
beautiful visuals he's ever seen Hudson
spent almost 16 years with the studio
beginning with his work I'll never win
tonight and md-82 Sony is being sued in
a class action suit for apparently
claiming that Killzone shadow fall was
delivering 1080p multiplayer graphics
when it wasn't the suit says that Sony
explicitly touted the 1080p visual
quality when in the words of those
taking them to court the graphics were
blurry to the point of a distraction
earlier this year digital foundry
discovered that the game uses a
technique called temporal reprojection
to achieve its resolution which is
clearly not satisfied this group of
gamers who claimed millions were tricked
into buying the shooter the report found
that kill zones multiplayer employed a
960 x 1080 frame buffer to run at 60
frames per second and the dev said
they'd be more precise about their
language in future sony has declined to
comment
that Assassin's Creed game being
developed exclusively the last
generation consoles has been officially
announced this week and we've got all
the details Assassin's Creed rogue is
coming and its main character is
assassin turned Templar Shay Patrick
Cormac the game is coming without
multiplayer and it's all based around
the Seven Years War that's between 1752
and 1761 if you're bad at history like
me Shay will have a ship called the
Morrigan and a lot of the game will be
naval combat and adventuring titled up
against land-based components all of
which will be peppered with mission road
will take place chronologically between
Assassin's Creed 3 and AC 4 black flag
rounding off the American saga next up
the floor v1 team shooter evolved has
been delayed until 2015 2k parent
company takes two explained they believe
extending the development by a few
months will let the team make evolve
into exactly what they want it to be CEO
Strauss Zelnick added historically we've
always benefited from giving the crater
change more time to polish the titles
we'd never regretted it originally the
co-operative shooter was going to land
on a turbo 21 and now gamers will have
to wait a tad longer until februari 10
finally and in what is clearly the most
important story of the week a fish is
playing pokemon on twitch good in things
that make you wonder what on earth were
achieving as a civilization which plays
pokemon seemed insane enough where tens
of thousands of people were
simultaneously inputting commands but
now it's just one set of commands from a
fish it's called fish place Pokemon
Grayson the fish lives in a fish tank
and his movements in said tank term in
what direction the little pixel ash goes
in response to frustrated gamers waiting
for ages for the fish to do something
his owners have said no the fish is not
dead he just sleeps sometimes
miraculously the fish has managed to
catch a Pokemon but otherwise progress
has been slow but you know anything is
possible Fisher about a games aside let
me know in the comment section
if you think the lawsuit against Sony in
regards to kill zone is fair all crazy
this week on site check out the most
awesome of co-op games on the chest can
make sure you know every little thing
about pc graphics and skyrim mods build
the ultimate gaming PC you can also
tweet your most awesome gaming moment at
James bus to win a ps4 if that's
something you want to do using our
hashtag greatest gaming moment also be
sure to be following up that is it for
me this week be sure to thank Chris for
hosting our Thursday show and i'll see
you again with more news on Monday